Hi, this is Kim Mills, host of Speaking of Psychology. Today we're sharing an episode from another podcast that we think you'll enjoy, call to mind from American Public Media. Call to Mind is American Public Media's initiative to foster new conversations about mental health. This episode, the strain of stress, looks at the many pressures Americans are facing today, from financial worries to political division, how chronic stress can affect both mental and physical health, and how to manage the strain. You'll hear from two familiar voices, Arthur C. Evans Jr., CEO of the American Psychological Association, and Dennis Stolley, APA's head of applied psychology. If you enjoy this episode, you can find more from the Call to Mind team at call tomind.org or wherever you get your
大家好，我是金·米尔斯，《心理学热线》的主持人。今天我们将分享另一档播客的节目，来自美国公共传媒的《铭记心间》，相信大家会喜欢。《铭记心间》是美国公共传媒发起的一个项目，旨在围绕心理健康展开新的对话。本期节目题为《压力的重担》，探讨了美国人当今面临的种种压力，从财务担忧到政治分歧，以及慢性压力如何影响身心健康，还有如何应对这种压力。大家将听到两个熟悉的声音：美国心理学会首席执行官小亚瑟·C·埃文斯，以及美国心理学会应用心理学负责人丹尼斯·斯托利。如果你喜欢这期节目，可以访问 call tomind.org 或在你获取
podcasts. We hope you enjoy this episode. You're listening to The Strain of Stress, a special report from call to mind, American Public Media's initiative to foster new conversations about mental health. I'm Angela Davis. What stresses me out? I think like most people, current times are very stressful. This is Gina Marie, a New Yorker who generously agreed to share her experiences with stress. As a black woman, a middle-aged black woman, I do not feel protected. at all. I wake up in the morning, almost with a coat of armor that I need to put on before I leave my house. I think that that just sets the foundation of stress even before I get to work.
播客的地方收听《铭记心间》团队的更多节目。希望你喜欢本期节目。你正在收听的是《压力的重担》，这是《铭记心间》的一期特别报道，《铭记心间》是美国公共传媒旨在促进心理健康新对话的项目。我是安吉拉·戴维斯。什么让我感到压力？我想和大多数人一样，当下的时代压力巨大。这位是吉娜·玛丽，一位纽约人，她大方地分享了自己对压力的体验。作为一个黑人女性，一个中年黑人女性，我完全感觉不到安全感。我早上醒来，出门前几乎需要穿上一层盔甲。我认为这甚至在上班之前就为压力奠定了基础。
Experts who study stress say it's deeply personal. And what stresses us can seem big or small, but almost anything can cause a person to feel stress. And now work is another circumstance. You know, the company I worked for just laid off almost 15. thousand people, I believe it was. Those of us who left me fine feel a great deal of stress and that my day could end at any moment. You know, as a mom, that makes me nervous. Gina Marie's family stress is real. She and her husband are foster parents on the way to adoption. And their case has been going for years. She says the love she feels for her kids is incredible, but it can't erase how overwhelming the journey has been.
研究压力的专家表示，压力是非常个人化的。让我们感到压力的事可大可小，但几乎任何事都能让人感到压力。现在工作成了又一种情况。你知道的，我供职的公司刚刚裁员了差不多15,000人，如果我没记错的话。我们这些留下来的人感到巨大的压力，觉得我的工作随时可能结束。你知道的，作为一个妈妈，这让我感到紧张。吉娜·玛丽家庭的压力是真实的。她和丈夫是正在办理收养手续的寄养父母。他们的案子已经持续了好几年。她说她对孩子们感到的爱是不可思议的，但这无法抹去这段旅程是多么令人不堪重负。
I had no idea. I was naive, admittedly, about the emotional toll, the marital toll, the everything toll that it takes. Just being in it now has presented several years of stress that I had not imagined I'd be having at this point in my life, being middle-aged and perimenopausal, which is another set of stress. Gina Marie's story shares something common about stress. It's rare for us to deal with one demanding,
我完全不知道。坦白地说，我曾经很天真，不知道它带来的情感代价、婚姻代价以及方方面面的代价。身处其中这几年，它带来的压力超出了我人生这个阶段的想象，我已经是中年，还正处于围绝经期，这又是一堆压力。吉娜·玛丽的故事反映了关于压力的一点共性。我们很少只应对一个艰巨的
at a time. Typically, there are many. And there's usually some nuance to what stresses us. For example, it's great to have family and friends, but sometimes family and friends are stressful. One thing is certain, we all have stress, and we can feel it. Think about situations where your heart starts to pound, or your mind begins to race. Maybe your palms get sweaty, or you feel like you are carrying an invisible weight. These are natural responses. These are natural responses. to stress, and they can overwhelm us. National surveys confirm people in the U.S. have experienced historic levels of stress since the COVID-19 pandemic started in 2020.
任务。通常有许多任务。而且让我们感到压力的事物通常都有一些微妙之处。例如，有家人和朋友固然很好，但有时家人和朋友也充满压力。有一点是肯定的，我们所有人都有压力，而且我们能感受到它。想想那些心跳加速或思绪狂飙的时刻。也许你手心出汗，或者觉得正扛着无形的重担。这些都是自然的反应。这些都是自然的反应。对压力的反应，它们会让我们不堪重负。全国调查证实，自2020年新冠疫情爆发以来，美国人一直经历着历史最高水平的压力。
And what stresses us out ranges from personal pressures, like money and jobs, to large societal issues like politics or the impact of racism. Experts warn that living with so much stress doesn't just make us feel bad in the moment. it can cause serious health issues. Chronic stress puts us more at risk for a mental illness or a substance use disorder. This report is about stress, the kinds of stress that we all deal with by just being alive. We won't cover trauma or post-traumatic stress disorder in this program, but we will talk about the everyday issues that overwhelm us and the impact of stress on our well-being.
让我们感到压力的因素从个人压力（如金钱和工作）到大型社会问题（如政治或种族主义的影响）不等。专家警告说，带着如此巨大的压力生活，不仅会让我们当下感觉糟糕，还会引发严重的健康问题。慢性压力会增加我们罹患精神疾病或物质使用障碍的风险。本报道关注的是压力，也就是我们作为普通人仅凭活着就要应对的各种压力。我们在本节目中不会探讨创伤或创伤后应激障碍，但我们会讨论那些让我们不堪重负的日常问题以及压力对我们福祉的影响。
I'll also talk with experts seeking solutions. and get tips on how to best manage stress. Let's start with Dr. Arthur Evans, Jr. in Washington, D.C. He's a clinical and community psychologist, and currently the CEO of the American Psychological Association. Dr. Evans says stress isn't inherently a bad thing. It can actually be useful. Stress actually helps us when we need to be motivated to do something.
我还将与寻求解决方案的专家交谈，并获取关于如何最好地管理压力的建议。让我们从华盛顿特区的亚瑟·埃文斯（Arthur Evans, Jr.）博士开始。他是一名临床和社区心理学家，目前担任美国心理学会的首席执行官。埃文斯博士表示，压力本质上并非坏事。它其实很有用。当我们做事需要动力时，压力实际上能提供帮助。
The problem is when that stress is very acute or when it's very intense, or when we are dealing with it over a very long period of time, that's when we really have to worry about stress in our lives. And there are different kinds of stress, too. There are absolutely different kinds of stress. There's certainly stress that is caused by psychological issues. That could be a relationship. That could be just dealing with what people are seeing happening in the world around us.
问题在于，当这种压力非常急性、非常强烈，或者当我们长期承受这种压力时，这才是我们真正需要担心生活中压力的时候。压力也有不同的种类。确实有不同种类的压力。当然有由心理问题引起的压力。那可能是一段关系。那可能只是应对人们所看到的周围世界正在发生的事情。
There's stress that's related to our ability to actually get things done. I'll tell you, when I was in graduate school, the stress that I looked at was, economic stress. Economic stressors can cause significant psychological distress. So when we see, for example, the economy have a downturn, we will also see an increase in the number of people coming into treatment. Dr. Arthur Evans Jr. says there are two main kinds of stress, acute stress and chronic stress. Acute stress is something that's short term.
还有与我们实际完成任务的能力相关的压力。我跟你说，我在读研究生时研究的压力是经济压力。经济压力源会导致显著的心理困扰。因此，举例来说，当我们看到经济下滑时，我们也会看到前来接受治疗的人数增加。小亚瑟·埃文斯博士表示，压力主要有两种：急性压力和慢性压力。急性压力是短期的。
It comes and goes quickly. like a difficult exam at school, or getting stuck in traffic when you're running late. Chronic stress is long-term. It can last months or even years. Living with relentless financial problems or caring for a really sick family member, Dr. Evans says chronic stress can trigger serious health issues, and you might start to recognize it's a problem when your work or your everyday activities get unusually challenging. And so what you start to see is,
它来得快去得也快。比如学校里的一场难考的考试，或者快迟到时堵在路上。慢性压力是长期的。它可以持续几个月甚至几年。生活在无休止的财务问题中，或者照顾一个重病的家庭成员，埃文斯博士表示，慢性压力会引发严重的健康问题，当你的工作或日常活动变得异常具有挑战性时，你可能会开始意识到这是一个问题。所以你开始看到的是，
problems in your activities of daily living. So if you're a parent, you start to see you're not on top of your parenting. If you're a worker, you're starting to see that your work is slipping. So the issue for us is really one, making sure that we understand what are the signs that we are stressed. I'll give you an example. One of the things that I know about me, I'm pretty optimistic person. And when I start to get cynical, I know that that's because I'm feeling stress. And so I've come to know that if I start to get a little cynical, I start to pay attention to, okay, so what's going on with me? Why am I feeling stress? And then I can take steps to deal with that. So what are some common mental illnesses that stress can actually trigger?
日常生活活动出现问题。如果你是父母，你会发现自己无法胜任做父母的职责。如果你是员工，你会发现自己的工作效率在下滑。所以对我们来说，真正的问题在于：第一，确保我们理解自己感到压力的迹象是什么。我举个例子。关于我自己，我知道的一点是，我是个相当乐观的人。当我开始变得愤世嫉俗时，我知道那是由于我感到了压力。因此我渐渐发现，如果我开始变得有点愤世嫉俗，我就会开始关注：好吧，我身上发生了什么？为什么我会感到压力？然后我就可以采取措施来应对它。那么，压力实际上可以引发哪些常见的精神疾病呢？
Certainly substance use. People can start drinking or using drugs as a way of managing their stress. One can become depressed. You know, post-traumatic stress syndrome is an anxiety disorder that is caused by experiencing a traumatic. event that was overwhelming to the person and having a stress reaction in relationship to how they recover and deal with that particular traumatic event. Dr. Evans says someone living with chronic stress is more likely to develop cardiovascular problems, type 2 diabetes, or a dangerously weakened immune system. It can also make existing mental health conditions worse. For nearly 20 years, the American Psychological Association has published an annual report called Stress in America. It's a national study about
当然是物质使用。人们可能会开始喝酒或吸毒，以此作为管理压力的一种方式。人可能会陷入抑郁。你知道，创伤后应激综合征是一种焦虑症，它是由经历了一场对个人而言不堪重负的创伤事件，并在如何恢复和应对该特定创伤事件方面产生压力反应而引起的。埃文斯博士表示，长期承受慢性压力的人更有可能患上心血管问题、2型糖尿病或免疫系统受损到危险程度。它还会使现有的心理健康状况恶化。近20年来，美国心理学会每年都会发布一份名为《美国压力》的报告。这是一项关于
what's stressing out people in the United States. And this year, half of the folks who participated set societal division stresses them out, and they feel more isolated because of it. Here's Dr. Evans. We know that social connection is enormously important to our health, probably one of the strongest predictors of how well we do in life. And what we're seeing is that the stress, Stressors, particularly around the social divide, are leading to people disconnecting from relationships that they have historically had. And we know that when people are less connected, that it leads to a whole variety of challenges. Loneliness can have a tremendous impact on our health status, both our psychological health and our physical health. And so if we look at stress from purely the standpoint of the stressors that we're experiencing,
美国人压力来源的全国性研究。而今年，一半的受访者表示，社会分裂给他们带来了压力，并且他们因此感到更加孤立。以下是埃文斯博士的讲话。我们知道社交联系对我们的健康极其重要，可能是预测我们生活状况良好的最强指标之一。而我们看到的是，压力，压力源，尤其是围绕社会分裂的压力，导致人们与他们历来拥有的关系断绝联系。我们知道，当人们的联系减少时，这会导致各种各样的挑战。孤独会对我们的健康状况产生巨大的影响，包括心理健康和身体健康。因此，如果我们纯粹从我们正在经历的压力源的角度来看待压力，
or only affecting the individual. What we're seeing is, no, it's affecting all of us, and it's affecting how we then relate to each other. And to the degree that we are more disconnected, that, in fact, exacerbates the impact that stress can have in our lives. Yes, the words societal division is in there a lot. But, you know, an interesting finding, 62% of adults in the U.S.
或者它不仅仅影响个人。我们所看到的是，不，它影响着我们所有人，并且它影响着我们彼此交往的方式。只要我们更加疏离，这实际上就会加剧压力在我们生活中产生的影响。是的，“社会分裂”这个词在里面出现了很多次。但是，你知道，一个有趣的发现是，62%的美国成年人
reported societal division was a significant source of stress in their lives. Yeah, and that was. was really surprising. If you think about this, half of Americans are feeling lonely and disconnected. That is just an astounding number that that many Americans are feeling like they don't have the adequate support. Those relationships are what keeps us healthy. Those are the things that are most related to our health status. When we think about what's at stake, when people are increasingly stressed about society, politics, and the nation, how can that show up? Yeah, well, one of the ways is that we stop trusting people who we should be in a more trusting relationship with. You know, society works
报告称，社会分裂是他们生活中压力的一个重要来源。是的，这真的很令人吃惊。如果你想想这一点，一半的美国人感到孤独和脱节。这是一个令人震惊的数字，那么多美国人觉得他们没有得到足够的支撑。这些关系正是保持我们健康的秘诀。这些与我们的健康状况最息息相关。当我们思考当人们对社会、政治和国家感到越来越大压力时，到底有什么在处于危险之中，这会如何表现出来呢？是的，其中一种表现形式是我们停止信任那些我们本应与之建立更多信任关系的人。你知道，社会的运转
when there is some level of trust. You trust the person who's teaching your child. You trust the health care provider that you're going to. You trust your colleague. When that starts to break down, it really impacts a lot of areas of our society. And I think, think all of us then need to be concerned when we know that there are these issues that are in our society that are leading to not only this disconnection, but this erosion of trust between one another. That's Dr. Arthur Evans Jr. from the American Psychological Association. You're listening to The Strain of Stress, a special report from Call to Mind. I'm Angela Davis. As we heard from Dr. Evans, political division is a significant source of stress for adults in the United States. And if it
建立在一定程度的信任之上。你信任教导你孩子的老师。你信任你去看病的医疗保健提供者。你信任你的同事。当这种信任开始崩溃时，它确实会影响我们社会的许多领域。我认为，我们所有人都需要感到担忧，当我们在社会中看到这些不仅导致这种脱节，还导致彼此之间信任侵蚀的问题时。这是来自美国心理学会的小亚瑟·埃文斯博士。你正在收听的是《压力的重担》，这是《铭记心间》的一期特别报道。我是安吉拉·戴维斯。正如我们从埃文斯博士那里听到的，政治分歧是美国成年人压力的一个重要来源。如果
feels like we are less politically united, that's true. And there's even some data to back it up. A long-running survey conducted by the University of Michigan, Stanford, and other universities found that Americans give their opposing political party the lowest approval rating since the 1960s. And these political riffs are fracturing some friendships and families. reporter Chris Benderov has more. This story begins where so much political division begins, on Facebook. In this case, with a woman named Sarah. We're not using her last name for privacy reasons.
感觉我们在政治上不那么团结了，这是事实。甚至有一些数据可以支持这一点。密歇根大学、斯坦福大学和其他大学进行的一项长期调查发现，美国人对反对党的好感度降到了20世纪60年代以来的最低点。这些政治分歧正在使一些友谊和家庭破裂。记者克里斯·本德雷夫将带来详细报道。这个故事从许多政治分歧开始的地方讲起——脸书（Facebook）。在这个故事中，主角是一位名叫莎拉的女性。出于隐私原因，我们没有使用她的姓氏。
Anyway, Sarah works as a Spanish interpreter. And way back in 2015, she got one of her most exciting assignments ever. And I was, you know, basically saying I'm really proud of myself. Today was a really important moment. I got to interpret for Michelle Obama. I mean, it was just, you know, me tooting my horn a little bit that I had gotten to meet her and got to interpret for her. Sarah's a Democrat, but she says the post was not explicitly political.
总之，莎拉是一名西班牙语口译员。早在2015年，她接到了她有生以来最激动人心的任务之一。我当时，你知道，基本上是在说我为自己感到骄傲。今天是一个非常重要的时刻。我有幸为米歇尔·奥巴马做口译。我的意思是，这简直就是，你知道，我稍微吹嘘了一下，因为我居然能见到她并为她做口译。莎拉是一名民主党人，但她说这篇帖子并非明确的政治贴。
I checked, by the way, the entire post was one sentence. Quote, I got to interpret for Michelle Obama today, and then two exclamation points. But soon, a lot of people Sarah knew started commenting under the post about their dislike for Michelle Obama and President Barack Obama, and they're dislike that Sarah had gone to the Obama White House. Now, Sarah grew up in a fairly conservative part of Colorado. She disagreed with people from her hometown online for years. But still, she was disheartened at how quickly a few of her friends had made things contentious.
顺便说一句，我查过了，整篇帖子只有一句话。原话是：“我今天有机会为米歇尔·奥巴马做口译，”然后是两个感叹号。但很快，莎拉认识的许多人在该帖子下方开始评论，表达他们对米歇尔·奥巴马和巴拉克·奥巴马总统的不满，以及他们对莎拉曾去过奥巴马白宫的不满。现在，莎拉在科罗拉多州一个相当保守的地区长大。多年来，她在网上一直与家乡的人意见不合。尽管如此，她还是对她的几个朋友这么快就把事情搞得充满火药味感到沮丧。
I did respond in my response was something along the lines of. It's really sad that you can't even be proud of me for an accomplishment. And then I did quietly unfriend them. I'd called up Sarah to talk about unfriending people over politics. But actually, this wasn't even the main Facebook event that I'd called about. It was something that happened. a little later in the 2016 election cycle. I don't remember a specific time,
我确实回复了，我的回复大致是这样的：真可悲，你们甚至不能为我取得的成就感到骄傲。然后我默默地取消了加他们为好友。我打电话给莎拉，是想聊聊因为政治原因取消好友的事。但实际上，这甚至都不是我打电话要谈的主要脸书事件。那是后来发生的事情。
but I do remember whenever it was, I told my husband, wow, my dad unfriended me. Sarah's dad lives near her in Colorado. He's a lifelong conservative Christian, but politics had never caused a rift between them before this. She says he was an outstanding dad who she lived with exclusively as a teenager after her parents divorced.
在2016年大选周期稍晚的时候。我不记得具体是什么时候了，但我确实记得无论何时，我告诉丈夫：“哇，我爸把我取消好友了。”莎拉的父亲住在科罗拉多州她家附近。他是一名终身保守派基督党人，但在此之前，政治从未在他们之间造成过裂痕。她说他是个了不起的父亲，在她父母离异后，她在青少年时期一直单独和他住在一起。
But as the 2016 presidential election ramped up, their conversations became more political, intense. We were just unable to have conversations. Every conversation he had had to be about politics. Would you actually, do you remember, would you say like, I don't know, Dad, let's talk about something else? Like, what were your... All the time. Oh, really? Did you have to be subtle about it? No, I have to be very direct about it. Dad, I don't want to talk about this. Sarah kept trying unsuccessfully to change the subject, but her dad wouldn't budge. And then finally, in 2016, he pulled away from Sarah. First, it was the Facebook unfriending, and then fewer and fewer phone calls.
但随着2016年总统大选的升温，他们的对话变得更加政治化、更加激烈。我们根本无法进行对话。他进行的每一次对话都必须是关于政治的。你会不会，你还记得吗，你会不会说，比如说，“爸，我们聊点别的吧？”就像，你的……一直这样。哦，真的吗？你得委婉一点吗？不，我必须非常直接。爸爸，我不想谈这个。莎拉不断地试图转移话题，但都没有成功，而她父亲就是不肯让步。最后，在2016年，他疏远了莎拉。首先是在脸书上取消好友，接着电话也越来越少。
We used to talk at least one or two times a week before, and then it got to the point where we talked maybe once a month. And so that switch of having him being very present in my life to not being present almost at all was really devastating. The situation was a shock to Sarah, but it was a scenario cropping up more and more for psychologist Joshua Coleman. I wrote my first book on estrangement in 2007, and I don't recall working with families who'd been estranged over politics, but now it's not uncommon at all. Coleman is the author of the book Rules of Estrangement. He lives in the San Francisco Bay Area, and he sees a lot of clients who've been estranged by other family members. But it never used to be over politics until Donald Trump first ran for president. Now, according to a survey Coleman commissioned, one in five estranged family members cite political differences as the college.
在此之前，我们过去每周至少通话一到两次，后来发展到可能一个月才通一次话。因此，他从在我的生活中非常活跃到几乎完全缺席，这种转变真的让人心碎。这种情况对莎拉来说是个打击，但对于心理学家约书亚·科尔曼（Joshua Coleman）来说，这种情形却越来越多地出现。我在2007年写了第一本关于疏离的书，我不记得曾与因政治观点而疏离的家庭共事过，但现在这已经一点也不罕见了。科尔曼是《疏离法则》一书的作者。他住在旧金山湾区，他接待了许多被其他家庭成员疏离的客户。但这从来都不是因为政治，直到唐纳德·特朗普首次竞选总统。现在，根据科尔曼委托进行的一项调查，五分之一疏离的家庭成员将政治分歧列为原因。
Because Coleman says typically it's a Trump-supporting parent being cut off by an anti-Trump child, so Sarah's case is a bit different. But in any case, Coleman thinks there are a couple reasons for all this. One is the more controversial and heated rhetoric that President Donald Trump has been charged with introducing to national politics. But Coleman thinks we're to blame too, because as a society, we seem to prize our political convictions more and more in recent decades. We're in an era where people are sort of led to believe. that their identities and the preservation of their mental health are the most important North Stars to orient themselves towards. And it turns out that's actually not really the case.
因为科尔曼说，通常是支持特朗普的父母被反特朗普的孩子断绝关系，所以莎拉的情况有点不同。但无论如何，科尔曼认为这一切有几个原因。一个是唐纳德·特朗普总统被指引入国家政治的更具争议和煽动性的言论。但科尔曼认为我们也有责任，因为作为一个社会，在过去的几十年里，我们似乎越来越看重我们的政治信念。我们处于这样一个时代：人们某种程度上被引导去相信，他们的身份认同和心理健康的维护是他们赖以指引自己的最重要的北极星。而事实证明，实际情况并非如此。
The research shows that it's a much more community and relationships and involvement and voluntary associations are much better on North Stars for happiness and resilience and joy. I should say that the research Coleman is pointing to shows social connections are strongly linked to happiness. It's harder to say for sure if they cause it. But either way, we know people fare better when they aren't lonely, and estrangement obviously stands in the way of that.
研究表明，社区、关系、参与和自愿结社才是通往幸福、韧性和快乐的更好北极星。我应该指出，科尔曼所指出的研究表明，社交联系与幸福感密切相关。如果说它们是导致幸福的原因，这就很难百分之百确定了。但无论如何，我们知道当人们不感到孤独时，他们的状况会更好，而疏离显然阻碍了这一点。
Coleman is open about the fact that he tends to be against the so-called no-contact movement. It's an increasingly common trend where people, often adult children, cut off all communication with certain family members when they experience the relationship is harmful or unmanageable. In full transparency, by the way, Joshua Coleman was estranged from his own adult daughter for years, although not over politics, and they've since reconciled. So what does he think people experiencing stress
科尔曼坦率地承认，他倾向于反对所谓的“无接触运动”。这是一个日益普遍的趋势，当人们（通常是成年子女）在经历有害或无法处理的关系时，会与某些家庭成员切断所有联系。顺便说一句，出于完全的透明度，约书亚·科尔曼曾与其成年女儿疏离多年，尽管不是因为政治原因，但他们此后已经和解了。那么，他认为那些因
over a political disagreement where the family member should do? Well, first off... It's good to be proactive, you know, before you go to that lunch or whatever, say, look, you know, let's just agree we're not going to talk about Trump or politics or, you know, Israel or whatever.
政治分歧而感到压力、纠结是否应该与家庭成员断绝关系的人该怎么做呢？好吧，首先……保持主动是件好事，你知道，在去吃午饭或做其他事情之前，先说：听着，你知道，让我们达成一致，我们不谈论特朗普、政治，或者，你知道，以色列或其他什么。
You know, it always goes poorly. So can we just have that agreement? And the person says, no, I want to talk about what I want to talk about, I don't limit what I can say, okay, well, you can, but I just want to let you know that I won't be participating in that conversation because I don't think it's very productive. Back in Colorado, Sarah's stalemate between her and her dad
你知道，这总是谈得很糟糕。所以我们能达成这个共识吗？如果对方说：“不，我想谈我想谈的事，你不能限制我能说什么。”好吧，你可以说，但我只是想让你知道，我不会参与那个对话，因为我认为这没什么建设性。回到科罗拉多州，莎拉和她父亲之间的僵局
that had started around Donald Trump's win in 2016, it extended well into 2017, Trump's first year in office. It went on for seven or eight months until finally. My husband actually called my dad and said, listen, you have one daughter and you're losing time with your daughter, you're losing time with your grandson. It's not worth it.
始于2016年唐纳德·特朗普获胜前后，一直持续到2017年特朗普的第一任期。这种情况持续了七八个月，直到最后。我丈夫实际上给我爸爸打了电话，然后说：“听着，你只有一个女儿，你正在失去和你女儿相处的时间，你正在失去和你外孙相处的时间。这不值得。”
You need to let it go and you need to be okay with Sarah not having the same political opinions as you do and that doesn't mean that you're any less of a person or that she's any less of a person. Do you remember what your dad said when your husband talked to him? He told him I'll pray about it.
“你需要放下它，你需要接受莎拉可能和你没有相同的政治观点，这并不意味着你就不如别人，或者她就不如别人。”你还记得你丈夫跟他谈话时，你爸爸是怎么说的吗？他告诉我丈夫：“我会为此祈祷的。”
And then what? And then I think he actually did go pray about it because he, I genuinely think he went and had a come to Jesus moment. I don't even say that lightly because all of a sudden it was like, I'm going to come to your house, and there was more phone calls. And so I was very happy to have him back. By the way, Sarah requested that I not interview her father, that she doesn't want to cause a new rift.
然后呢？然后我想他确实去祈祷了，因为我真心觉得他去经历了一个“皈依”的时刻。我甚至不是随口说说的，因为突然之间，就像是：“我要去你家，”然后电话也变多了。所以我很高兴他能回来。顺便说一句，莎拉要求我不要采访她的父亲，她不想引起新的裂痕。
Sarah's husband confirmed the basic outlines of the story, though. Sarah did want me to clarify that she is not in favor of reconciliation in all cases. She says if someone has a toxic or abusive relationship with a close family member, then it can be best to let go of that relationship. But that's not the relationship Sarah had with her father before all this. Which aligns with what I heard from Joshua Coleman. He agrees sometimes there have to be hard boundaries. Like, for instance, if someone's parent kept demeaning
不过，莎拉的丈夫证实了故事的基本大纲。莎拉确实想澄清，她并不赞成在所有情况下都进行和解。她说，如果某人与亲密家庭成员的关系是有毒的或虐待性的，那么放弃这种关系可能是最好的选择。但莎拉在这一切发生之前和她父亲的关系并非如此。这与我从约书亚·科尔曼那里听到的一致。他同意有时必须划定严格的界限。比如，如果某人的父母不断贬低
or insulting the sexuality of their grandchild. But even then, Coleman says, I think people deserve kind of a period of education where you're sort of saying, look, We can either agree that I know you feel, you've already told me, I don't need to hear it again, and we can either agree that we're going to have different ideas about this and you'll never speak of it again, or it's going to make it really hard for me to want to spend time with you. You get to decide, mom or dad, kind of thing.
或侮辱他们孙辈的性取向。但即便如此，科尔曼说，我认为人们应该得到一段教育期，你可以这样说：“听着，我们可以达成一致，我知道你的感受，你已经告诉我了，我不需要再听一遍，我们要么同意我们对这件事会有不同的看法，而且你以后再也不要提起它，要么这会让我很难想和你共度时光。由你来决定，爸爸或妈妈。”
As for Sarah and her dad, their reconciliation in 2017 was not entirely permanent. There have been ups and downs. During COVID, Sarah and her dad nearly had a falling out again over her getting the COVID vaccine while pregnant. her dad was convinced it would harm the baby, which it did not. But overall, even though nationally politics are more divisive than ever, Sarah says she and her dad are in a good place. I talk to him every single day. You talk to him every day now. Every day. I see him at least once a week.
至于莎拉和她的父亲，他们在2017年的和解并非完全一成不变。其中也有起起落落。在新冠疫情期间，莎拉和她的父亲几乎又因为她在怀孕期间接种新冠疫苗而闹翻。她父亲坚信这会伤害婴儿，而事实并非如此。但总体而言，尽管全国范围内的政治比以往任何时候都更具分裂性，但莎拉表示她和父亲的状况很好。我每天都跟他说话。你现在每天都跟他说话？每一天。我每周至少见他一次。
We usually go down there on Saturday or Sunday with our kids and spend the afternoon with him. We have a very loving relationship. and, you know, when he does get a little heated about politics, I typically just say, dad, I don't want to talk about this, or I'll just leave my husband talking politics with him and I'll walk out of the room, but we have learned how to manage our emotions and just prioritize the fact that we're family.
我们通常会在周六或周日带着孩子去他那里，和他在下午共度时光。我们有着非常充满爱的关系，而且，你知道，当他因政治问题而情绪略微激动时，我通常会说：“爸爸，我不想谈这个，”或者我会让我丈夫继续跟他谈政治，然后我走出房间，但我们已经学会了如何管理我们的情绪，并且优先考虑我们是一家人这个事实。
Sarah and the psychologist Joshua Coleman have a couple things in common. First, and Coleman confirmed this with me, they are both not fans of President Trump and his policies. But also, while he's not fans of President Trump and his policies, it isn't always possible, they both believe in attempting to maintain your closest connections across stark political divisions. Because if you don't, it might not just hurt the other person. It might hurt you just as much. For call to mind, I'm Chris Benderev. Let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll tell you about an industry that's trying to stay afloat,
莎拉和心理学家约书亚·科尔曼有一些共同点。首先——科尔曼也向我证实了这一点——他们都不喜欢特朗普总统及其政策。但同时，尽管他不喜欢特朗普总统及其政策，他们俩都相信，跨越巨大的政治分歧，努力维持你最亲密的联系并非不可能。因为如果你不这样做，它可能不仅会伤害对方。它可能会同样深深地伤害你。我是克里斯·本德雷夫，为《铭记心间》报道。我们休息一下。广告回来后，我们将向您介绍一个正艰难维系的行业，
while trade, turmoil, and financial strain are causing the workers to wonder if they should just give up and get out. That's coming up on The Strain of Stress, a call to Mind special report from American Public Media. Welcome back to The Strain of Stress, a special report from Call to Mind, American Public Media's initiative to foster new conversations about mental health. I'm Angela Davis. My name is Andrew. I live in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. Something that stresses me out is the expenses of everyday life in America right now. Expenses continue to rise on what feels like a monthly basis. It costs more to keep my car insured. It's going to cost more for rent next year. It costs more to get food and groceries. I am on an Affordable Care Act plan.
贸易动荡和财务压力让工人们开始怀疑他们是否应该直接放弃并退出。精彩内容即将呈现，敬请收听《压力的重担》，这是美国公共传媒推出的一期《铭记心间》特别报道。欢迎回到《压力的重担》，这是《铭记心间》的一期特别报道，《铭记心间》是美国公共传媒发起的一项旨在促进心理健康新对话的项目。我是安吉拉·戴维斯。我叫安德鲁。我住在宾夕法尼亚州费城。让我感到压力的一件事是目前美国日常生活中的开销。生活开销似乎以按月为单位持续上涨。我的汽车保险费用增加了。明年的房租会更贵。买食物和杂货的花费也更高了。我使用的是《平价医疗法案》的保险方案。
I fear that my premiums will go up by hundreds of dollars monthly. That is a major source of stress. And things that would typically bring me relief from stress in everyday life, such as streaming TV shows or movies, those leisure activities are also getting more expensive. A way that it's impacting my mental health is that it's hard to even get relief from these everyday stressors. That was Andrew.
我担心我的保费每月会增加几百美元。这是一个主要的压力来源。而那些通常能减轻我日常生活中压力的事情，比如观看流媒体电视剧或电影，这些休闲活动也变得越来越昂贵。它对我的心理健康产生的影响是，甚至很难从这些日常压力源中获得解脱。刚才那位是安德鲁。
He's a media producer in Philadelphia. Earlier in the hour, we heard that chronic stress, persistent and long-term pressure, is tied to serious health problems. Chronic stress can trigger mental health challenges and make existing mental illnesses worse. National surveys report one of the most common and often the primary source of stress in our lives is work. Whether it's hustle culture, a difficult workload, conflict among colleagues, or never being able to get a ahead, nearly seven in 10 employed adults identify work-related stress as a significant burden. High on the list of work stress, a difficult or toxic workplace. Also high on the list, job insecurity. A good example is the agricultural industry. Farmers face a lot of job
他是费城的一名媒体制作人。在节目刚开始时，我们听说慢性压力——持续长期的压力——与严重的健康问题息息相关。慢性压力会引发心理健康挑战，并使现有的精神疾病恶化。全国性调查报告显示，我们生活中最常见、通常也是主要的压力来源之一就是工作。无论是奋斗文化、沉重的工作负荷、同事之间的冲突，还是永远无法出人头地，近十分之七的受雇成年人将与工作相关的压力视为沉重的负担。在工作压力的清单中，排名靠前的是困难或有毒的工作场所。同样排名靠前的是工作的不稳定性。农业就是一个很好的例子。农民面临着很多工作
insecurities. There's trade conflict, rising costs, climate change, and farmers bear the brunt of it all. Studies show that all of this leads to increased rates of stress, depression, and suicide in farm country. Mental health providers say some farmers seek help, but they also say our health care system needs to rethink how care is delivered to farmers. Minnesota Public Radio's Molly Castlework and Tadillo-Ruey's San Have more. It's a chilly November day in north central Minnesota. Dave Gary, a soybean and corn farmer, is driving his truck heading home. He just dropped off some of his corn harvest at a grain elevator in the town of Warren. This is where most farmers in the area sell their crops. Dave expects his corn to sell at a loss due to ongoing international trade turmoil that is
不稳定性。贸易冲突、不断上涨的成本、气候变化，而农民承担了这一切的后果。研究表明，所有这一切导致了农场地区压力、抑郁和自杀率的上升。心理健康服务提供者表示，一些农民会寻求帮助，但他们也指出，我们的医疗保健系统需要重新思考如何向农民提供护理。明尼苏达公共广播电台的莫莉·卡斯尔沃克和塔迪洛·鲁伊·山将带来详细报道。这是11月一个寒冷的日子，位于明尼苏达州中北部。大卫·加里（Dave Gary），一位大豆和玉米种植户，正开着卡车回家。他刚刚把一些玉米收成卸到沃伦镇的一个谷仓电梯里。这里是该地区大多数农民出售农作物的地方。由于国际贸易持续动荡，大卫预计他的玉米将亏本出售，这
hitting corn prices hard. It's a situation that's made the local grain elevator feel to Gary less like a place of commerce and more like a casino. It's a crapshoot. It's the roll of the dice. Two years ago, Dave Gary almost went bankrupt after a business he contracted with to sell his crop of sunflower seeds went bust. We couldn't pay our bills.
严重打击了玉米价格。这种情况让加里觉得当地的谷仓电梯与其说是一个商业场所，不如说更像是一个赌场。这纯粹是碰运气。全凭掷骰子。两年前，大卫·加里差点破产，因为他签约出售向其出售葵花籽收成的公司倒闭了。我们付不起账单。
It about took us out of farming. It really did. If it wasn't for our family, we probably would. would have been done farming. If farming was ever once a simple life, it no longer is. Today, more farmers are piling up high levels of debt and filing for bankruptcy. The average age of farmers continues to skew older and few young people are interested in continuing farm work. Dave says this has stressed both him and his wife. She's like, why do you want to keep doing this? Now it's in my blood. I don't know what else to do.
这差点把我们逼得不再种地。真的。如果不是因为我们的家庭，我们可能已经不种地了。如果农业曾经是一种简单的生活，那它现在已经不再是了。如今，越来越多的农民背负着高额债务并申请破产。农民的平均年龄持续偏老，很少有年轻人对继续从事农业工作感兴趣。大卫说，这给他和他的妻子都带来了压力。她说：“你为什么还要继续这样做？”现在这已经流淌在我的血液里。我不知道还能做什么。
Dave Gary's family arrived to the United States in the 1900s via ship from Ireland. His grandparents survived the Great Depression while his parents weathered the 1980s farm crisis. So there's a little legacy there, and I don't want to be the generation that loses the family farm. But it's getting tougher and tougher to hold on every year. Gary is like many American farmers today, feeling isolated, unprofitable, and putting huge amounts of pressure on themselves to keep the farm going. Tracy Rutherford itself is an agricultural mental health specialist for the state of Minnesota. She says the mental health landscape for farmers across the country is unsettling. I always ask people about suicide.
大卫·加里的家人在20世纪初乘船从爱尔兰来到美国。他的祖父母在大萧条中幸存下来，而他的父母则经受住了20世纪80年代的农场危机。所以这里有一点传承，我不想成为那个失去家族农场的代际。但要坚持下去，每年都变得越来越艰难。加里就像如今许多美国农民一样，感到孤立无援，无利可图，并给自己施加了巨大的压力，以维持农场的运营。特蕾西·卢瑟福-瑟夫（Tracy Rutherford-Self）本身是明尼苏达州的农业心理健康专家。她表示，全国农民的心理健康状况令人不安。我总是问人们关于自杀的问题。
I mean, when I'm working with farmers, are going to be one of my first questions. Farming is one of the industries with the highest risk for suicide. A common thread? Finances, especially, are taking their toll. Purdue University reported that nationally, farmers are feeling more pessimistic about the future of U.S. agriculture. The feeling rose sharply at the start of 2026 amid growing economic concerns. And Rutherford itself says finances have been extra unpredictable lately with the rapidly changing
我是说，当我与农民共事时，这将是我的首要问题之一。农业是自杀风险最高的行业之一。共同的线索是什么？尤其是财务状况正在付出代价。普渡大学报告称，在全国范围内，农民对美国农业的未来感到更加悲观。在日益增长的经济担忧背景下，这种情绪在2026年初急剧上升。卢瑟福-瑟夫本人表示，由于快速变化的
federal tariff policies. Right now, for many farmers, things change, again, almost daily. markets will swing because of things that are happening at the government level. The amount of things that you can control the year are shrinking and shrinking. That's Kayla Rosannaau, a corn and soybean farmer who lives in Northeast North Dakota. Kaler became a full-time farmer two years before the U.S. enter the trade war with China, a major American trade partner. That cost Rosanna to bleed money.
联邦关税政策，最近财务状况变得格外难以预测。现在，对许多农民来说，情况再次发生了变化，几乎每天都在变。市场会因为政府层面发生的事情而剧烈波动。你一年中能够控制的事情越来越少。那是凯拉·罗萨诺（Kayla Rosannau），一位住在北达科他州东北部的玉米和大豆种植户。凯拉在美国卷入与美国主要贸易伙伴中国的贸易战前两年成为了一名全职农民。这导致罗萨诺血本无归。
It just came all together to a point where you, you, you, You just didn't feel like you had control of anything, and it was very frustrating. Government subsidies helped Kaler stay afloat. Barely. Now, amidst the second agricultural trade war, Rosanna's wallet is once again under strain. And once more, he's expecting government farm subsidies to help some, but not enough. How many years can we keep doing this? How many years are we going to have the social capital of the American taxpayer to keep bailing
这一切汇聚到了一点，让你，让你，让你，你只是觉得你对任何事情都没有控制权，这非常令人沮丧。政府补贴帮助凯拉勉强维持了生计。勉强而已。现在，在第二场农业贸易战中，罗萨诺的钱包再次承受压力。再次，他预计政府的农场补贴会有所帮助，但还不够。我们还能这样坚持几年？我们还要花多少美国纳税人的社会资本来继续救助
now with the American farmer, which we don't want the payments. We just want the price of the market. Who do you talk to about this? It's got to go somewhere, right? Like, I can't imagine it's healthy or easy to just keep in. Well, I've got a lot of farmer friends, and we're all in the same boat, talking to them. they share they're in the same situation you are talking to them, talking over, seeing what they're going to do. It gives you kind of some reassurances that you're not the only one going through this. Farmers in the U.S. have a reputation for stoicism. So when therapy is based on talk, it can be hard to get them to come in and speak with a stranger about their problems.
现在的美国农民，而我们并不想要这些补贴。我们只想要市场价格。你跟谁谈论这件事？总得有个宣泄的出口，对吧？我是说，我无法想象把这些憋在心里是健康或轻松的。嗯，我有很多农民朋友，我们都在同一条船上，跟他们交谈。他们分享说他们处于和你一样的处境，跟他们交谈，讨论这些，看他们打算怎么做。这会给你一种安心感，让你觉得不是只有你一个人在经历这一切。美国的农民以坚忍著称。因此，当心理治疗基于谈话时，很难让他们进来并与陌生人谈论他们的问题。
It's just very difficult for farmers to ask for help. You know, they're very independent, so I think they just really try. to solve their own problems. That's Cynthia Christensen, a therapist in Minnesota, who has counseled farmers for 18 years. Christensen grew up on an Iowa cattle farm and says she understands how farmers can feel judge for admitting that they're struggling.
农民真的很难开口寻求帮助。你知道，他们非常独立，所以我认为他们真的只是在试图。自己解决问题。那是辛西娅·克里斯滕森（Cynthia Christensen），明尼苏达州的一名治疗师，她为农民提供咨询已有18年。克里斯滕森在爱荷华州的一个养牛场长大，她说她理解农民在承认自己苦苦挣扎时如何感到被评判。
There's a lot of stigma attached to seeking a therapist in the rural environment. I wish I wasn't saying that, but I think it's, I feel like people, it takes a lot of courage for somebody to call me. So, if mental health professionals want to help more farmers, Kristen said and her colleague Tracy Rutherford-Self say the industry needs to rethink how their services are provided. For example, Rutherford-Self visits her clients
在农村环境中，寻求治疗师伴随着很大的污名。我希望我没这么说，但我认为，我觉得人们，给远道而来的我打电话需要很大的勇气。因此，如果心理健康专业人士想帮助更多的农民，克里斯滕森和她的同事特蕾西·卢瑟福-瑟夫表示，该行业需要重新思考其服务提供的方式。例如，卢瑟福-瑟夫拜访她的客户
on the farm or neutral spots like community college campuses. They don't want to be seen coming into an office, and that's not even stigma. There's some reality to, hey, if somebody sees me going into a therapy office, what are they going to think about me? And what they think about me, literally could impact my livelihood. Rutherford Self says if the local banker knows a farmer is struggling, it might be harder for that client to get a loan for seed or a new tractor. And if mental health providers want to build trust with their clients, they need to show that they understand the unique pressures of farming.
在农场或社区学院校园等中立场所。他们不想被看到走进办公室，这甚至还不是社会污名的问题。这有其现实原因，嘿，如果有人看到我走进治疗办公室，他们会怎么想我？而他们对我的看法，实际上可能会影响我的生计。卢瑟福-瑟夫说，如果当地的银行家知道一个农民正在苦苦挣扎，该客户可能更难获得种子或新拖拉机的贷款。如果心理健康服务提供者想与客户建立信任，他们需要表现出他们了解农业的独特压力。
Rutherford's self says she explains early on in sessions about her own rural upbringing and that her husband comes from a farm family. If farmers do come in for a therapy session, out of touch comments can discourage them from returning. At a client who recently told me they went to see a provider and at the end of the session, the provider told them that they would just be better off not farming. And while on some level, there actually may be some truth to that as far as finances and stress, I think it really shows a lack of understanding of what our farmers really value and that is legacy and being able to continue to do the work. Tracy Rutherford-self says not only do communities need to train more providers to work in rural areas,
卢瑟福-瑟夫说，她在会谈早期会解释自己成长于农村的背景，以及她的丈夫来自一个农场家庭。如果农民真的来参加心理治疗会谈，不合时宜的评论会打消他们再次前来的念头。我有一个客户最近告诉我，他们去看了一位治疗师，在会谈结束时，治疗师告诉他们，他们最好不要种地。虽然在某种程度上，就财务和压力而言，这实际上可能包含一些真相，但我认为这确实表明了对我们的农民真正珍视的东西——也就是传承以及能够继续从事这项工作——缺乏理解。特蕾西·卢瑟福-瑟夫表示，社区不仅需要培训更多的服务提供者在农村地区工作，
but the mental health care system also needs to think more expansively about who can help. I have a really big philosophy that if you wait for the first call to come straight to me, we're going to miss people. When people are struggling, especially farmers, their first call isn't to a therapist. It's to family, a friend. Rutherford's self says mental health providers should leverage this, training all kinds of community members to recognize mental health warning signs. She's training some bankers right now because they're often the first to hear if a farmer is struggling financially. Christensen suggests that more everyday people and rural communities should get trained to recognize and watch for the signs of mental health issues.
然而，心理健康护理系统也需要更广泛地思考谁能够提供帮助。我有一个非常坚定的理念：如果你等着第一个求助电话直接打给我，我们就会错过许多人。当人们陷入挣扎时，尤其是农民，他们的第一通电话往往不是打给治疗师，而是打给家人或朋友。拉瑟福德自己表示，心理健康服务提供者应该利用这一点，培训各种社区成员识别心理健康警示信号。她目前正在培训一些银行职员，因为他们往往最先听到农民在经济上陷入困境。克里斯滕森建议，更多普通人和农村社区成员应该接受培训，以识别和关注心理健康问题的迹象。
In rural communities, you know, because of the population numbers, you know, we all. all have to kind of know some CPR, something about the Heimlich maneuver. And I think it's the same kind of life-saving thing that we know something about the questions that we can ask to see if our neighbors are struggling with their mental health. The farmers we met for this story, Dave Gary and Kayla Rosanna both say they're not planning to seek mental health support right now. Dave laughs, actually, when I ask him about the hardships. He says he's going to rely on his friends. And they, in turn, rely on him. I get a lot of calls from friends and neighbors that are having tough days,
在农村社区，你知道，由于人口数量的原因，你知道，我们大家都必须懂得一些心肺复苏术，或者海姆立克急救法的一些知识。我认为，这是一种同样的救命技能，我们需要了解我们可以提出哪些问题，来看看我们的邻居是否在与心理健康问题作斗争。我们为这篇报道采访的两位农民——戴夫·加里和凯拉·罗萨娜——都表示他们目前并不打算寻求心理健康支持。当我问起生活的艰难时，戴夫甚至笑了起来。他说他会依靠他的朋友们，而朋友们反过来也会依靠他。我经常接到朋友和邻居的电话，他们经历着艰难的日子，
and they don't want to take it home with them, so they end up calling you and you talk them. Off to ledge. But mental health experts say Dave Gary's approach isn't sustainable for everyone. They say the mental health system across the country needs to adapt so that farmers like Dave Gary trust that when they are struggling or stressed, they can come in and get help. For Call to Mind, I'm Molly Castlework.
他们不想把负面情绪带回家，所以最后会给你打电话，你就会和他们谈心，帮他们度过难关。但心理健康专家表示，戴夫·加里的这种方法并不适合所有人。他们说，全国的心理健康系统需要进行调整，以便像戴夫·加里这样的农民在感到挣扎或压力时，能够信任并前来寻求帮助。我是莫莉·卡斯尔沃克，为您报道“呼唤心灵”（Call to Mind）。
And I'm Today or Ruiz Sandoval in Minnesota. You're listening to The Strain of Stress, a special report from Call to Mind. I'm Angela Davis. At this point in the hour, it should be clear that ongoing stress is bad for us. Not only does it change our mood, but it can damage our health and well-being. being. Psychologist Alyssa Epple at the University of California, San Francisco, is an international expert on stress. Alyssa has contributed groundbreaking research on how stress changes the brain and can even accelerate aging. Here's Dr. Epple. We know from many studies now that chronic stress
我是明尼苏达州的托迪娅·鲁伊斯·桑多瓦尔。您收听的是“压力之压”（The Strain of Stress），这是“呼唤心灵”的一期特别报道。我是安吉拉·戴维斯。在这个小时的节目进行到这里，大家应该已经清楚，持续的压力对我们有害。它不仅会改变我们的情绪，还会损害我们的健康和福祉。加州大学旧金山分校的心理学家阿莉莎·埃普尔是压力研究领域的国际专家。阿莉莎为压力如何改变大脑甚至加速衰老做出了具有突破性的研究贡献。下面听听埃普尔博士的讲解。我们现在从许多研究中得知，慢性压力
actually changes the structure of the brain. It can shrink parts of the brain like the hippocampus, which is so sensitive for memory and emotion processing. It can enlarge the amygdala, which again makes us more sensitive to threat. And it can damage or impair our prefrontal cortex, our ability to really regulate stress and problem solved. Can you give me an example of how chronic stress could change a person's cognition or how it would change the brain? It creates cognition that's much more narrowly focused. on looking for stress and danger in our environment. And so instead of seeing beauty or noticing what's right, it's the opposite.
实际上会改变大脑的结构。它会使大脑的某些部分萎缩，比如对记忆和情绪处理极其敏感的海马体；它会使杏仁核变大，这反过来又让我们对威胁更加敏感；它还会损害或削弱我们的前额叶皮层，即我们真正调节压力和解决问题的能力。你能给我举个例说明慢性压力如何改变一个人的认知，或者它将如何改变大脑吗？它创造了一种认知，这种认知更加狭隘地专注于寻找我们环境中的压力和危险。因此，它不再去发现美或注意到正确的事物，而是恰恰相反。
So it's like focusing on what could go wrong rather than being present in the moment and appreciating what is there in front of you and what is good? Exactly. When we're stressed, our bodies release cortisol to stay alert. And cortisol signals glucose, which is sugar, that gives us a boost of energy during stressful time. So when cortisol is constantly triggering glucose and other hormones that activate during stress,
所以这就好比专注于可能出错的事情，而不是活在当下、欣赏眼前存在的东西以及美好的事物？完全正确。当我们感到压力时，我们的身体会释放皮质醇以保持警觉。皮质醇会向葡萄糖（即糖分）发出信号，在压力时期给我们提供能量提升。因此，当皮质醇不断触发葡萄糖以及在压力下被激活的其他荷尔蒙时，
that's when problems can show up in our bodies. Our blood pressure can change. Our metabolism might slow down. And even our bones can get weaker. Dr. Alyssa Eppel says some people gain weight or develop belly fat. But there are other clues, changes in our well-being to look for if the flood of cortisol becomes a problem. When we feel that we are not able to sleep well due to stress, that is one of the biggest signs that we better pay attention and make some changes to manage our daily stress response.
问题就会在我们的身体中显现出来。我们的血压可能会发生变化，我们的新陈代谢可能会减慢，甚至我们的骨骼也会变弱。阿莉莎·埃普尔博士表示，有些人会体重增加或长出腹部脂肪。但是，如果皮质醇的泛滥成为一个问题，还有其他的迹象和福祉的变化需要我们去留意。当我们感到由于压力而无法好好睡觉时，这就是最大的迹象之一，表明我们最好给予关注并做出一些改变来管理日常的压力反应。
When we are feeling particularly irritable, when our appetite becomes untied to meal times, and we just feel hungry all the time, when we feel lack of appetite, those are often signs. under chronic stress. I think we've all felt that our stress can age us, but your research has found it actually does. How does stress age a person? When we have a stress response that's prolonged and we don't get recovery, we know that the cellular aging processes are impaired and accelerated. So, for example, when we have chronic stress for years and years, we tend to debilitary. We tend to debilers. We're develop inflammation. We tend to develop shorter telomeres. That means our cells can't go on and keep replicating and dividing and replenishing tissue. We also are changing our epigenetic patterns.
当我们感到特别烦躁，当我们的食欲与进食时间脱节、总是感觉饿，或者当我们感到食欲不振时，这些通常都是处于慢性压力下的迹象。我想我们都曾感觉到压力会使我们衰老，但你的研究发现它确实如此。压力是如何使一个人衰老的呢？当我们有长期的压力反应且得不到恢复时，我们知道细胞衰老过程会受损并加速。所以，举个例子，当我们经历数年乃至数十年的慢性压力时，我们往往会变得衰弱。我们往往会产生炎症。我们往往会出现更短的端粒。这意味着我们的细胞无法继续复制、分裂和补充组织。我们也在改变我们的表观遗传模式。
And so we now know that we can measure how old our cells are and that chronic stress accelerates our epigenetic age. The term Dr. Eppel just used epigenetic age is a measure of a person's biological age, not the calendar. Instead of counting the years a person has been alive, epigenetic age reflects how fast our cells are aging due to our genetics, lifestyle, environment, and stress. All of our organs are vulnerable to the effects of chronic stress. The common pathway is the immune system. Stress causes premature aging of the immune system. And of course, that is the fuel source and the life source for every cell in our bodies. Are people who, you know, have many beautiful high stress moments like the winning athletes or
因此，我们现在知道我们可以测量我们的细胞有多大年龄，而慢性压力会加速我们的表观遗传年龄。埃普尔博士刚刚使用的术语“表观遗传年龄”是衡量一个人生物学年龄的标准，而不是日历年龄。表观遗传年龄不是计算一个人活了多少年，而是反映了由于我们的基因、生活方式、环境和压力，我们的细胞衰老有多快。我们所有的器官都容易受到慢性压力影响。共同的途径是免疫系统。压力会导致免疫系统过早衰老。当然，这是我们体内每个细胞的能量来源和生命之源。那些有许多美好的、高压时刻的人，比如获胜的运动员或
business owners who love their jobs, but they have a lot of stress to keep it going? Can that good stress? Can that accelerate aging? In general, no, they don't because our body is exquisitely adapted to recover from those peaks of stress arousal. The hard part is that we really need to be honest with ourselves and ask, is this good stress or is this too much, too much of a good thing in a sense? That's Dr. Alyssa Epple from the University of California, San Francisco. We'll hear from her again later. You're listening to The Strain of
热爱自己工作但为了维持现状而承受巨大压力的企业主呢？那种压力是好压力吗？那会加速衰老吗？总的来说，不会，因为我们的身体极其适应从这些压力激增的高峰中恢复过来。困难的部分在于，我们需要对自己绝对诚实并询问：这是好压力，还是从某种意义上说，一件好事做得太多了？这是来自加州大学旧金山分校的阿莉莎·埃普尔博士。稍后我们将再次听到她的分享。您收听的是“压力之
Stress, a special report from Call to Mine. I'm Angela Davis. People generally think of stress as a negative feeling, but as we've learned, stress can also be positive. For example, people who work in health care can experience tremendous stress in their jobs. Each day they are tasked with high-stakes decision-making and work with folks who are dealing with illness, pain, or medical emergencies. But after seeing a patient pull through a difficult episode, a health care worker may not feel stress. They feel joy. But as we just heard from Dr. Alyssa Epple, an important question to ask is, when is stress, even the good kind, just too much? Call to mine's Jessica Barrow. takes us to a big city hospital.
压”，这是一期来自“呼唤心灵”的特别报道。我是安吉拉·戴维斯。人们通常认为压力是一种负面感觉，但正如我们所了解的，压力也可以是积极的。例如，在医疗保健领域工作的人在其工作中可能会经历巨大的压力。每天，他们都背负着高风险的决策任务，并与应对疾病、疼痛或医疗紧急情况的人们打交道。但在看到患者度过艰难关头后，医护人员可能不会感到压力，而是会感到喜悦。但正如我们刚刚从阿莉莎·埃普尔博士那里听到的那样，一个重要的问题是：压力——甚至是好的那种压力——在什么时候就会变得过头了？“呼唤心灵”的杰西卡·巴罗将带我们走进一家大城市医院。
This is the TVF. This is the triage, please. This is the emergency department at Rush University Medical Center in Chicago. It looks similar to a hospital
这是创伤复苏室。请注意，这是分诊区。这是芝加哥拉什大学医学中心的急诊科。它看起来类似于你在
you might see on a nighttime TV show. Staff and scrubs and white coats are quickly moving in and out of their workstations. There are constant beeps and ringing noises. I'm here to meet. Corey Goldstein, and I am an attending physician in the emergency department. Dr. Corey Goldstein is supervising the shift tonight.
深夜电视剧中看到的医院。穿着刷手服和白大褂的工作人员在他们的工作站之间快速进出。到处都是不断的蜂鸣声和铃声。我来这里是为了见科里·戈德斯坦，我是急诊科的主治医师。科里·戈德斯坦博士今晚负责监督这个班次。
He's in his 50s and has practiced emergency medicine for almost a decade. The first thing Dr. Goldstein does to start his hospital shift is a sign-off meeting with the morning team. They cycle through their cases. All right. Next one. Female in our 30s, history of basically anxiety on copra analal. Coming in with bilateral language. 68-year-old male, presenter AD with abdominal pain and his hip diabetes,
他五十多岁，从事急诊医学近十年了。戈德斯坦博士开始医院值班的第一件事是与早班团队进行交接会议。他们轮流讨论病例。好的，下一个。三十多岁女性，有基础焦虑病史，正在服用抗抑郁药。因双侧语言障碍前来就诊。68岁男性，因腹痛和髋关节糖尿病到急诊科就诊，
and hypertension. He was very tender to the right. Mid-40s male with HIV disorder. There are about 90 patients in the emergency department and another 20 people waiting in the lobby. The unit is busy. Rush University Medical Center is a level-2 trauma hospital. That means the staff typically doesn't treat gunshot injuries
并伴有高血压。他的右侧有非常明显的触痛。四十多岁男性，伴有艾滋病毒感染。急诊科大约有90名患者，大厅里还有另外20人在等待。这个科室很忙。拉什大学医学中心是一家二级创伤医院。这意味着医护人员通常不治疗枪伤
or survivors of bad car accidents. But any shift could involve heart attacks, overdose cases, bad allergic reactions, stroke symptoms, and all manner of illness. There is no way of knowing what will happen each shift, which in itself seems stressful. Once the sign-off meeting is finished, Dr. Goldstein starts making rounds. So the patient I'm going to go see has multiple medical issues, including a organ transplant. I tag along, but I don't go into any examinations to respect people's privacy.
或严重车祸的幸存者。但任何一个班次都可能涉及心脏病发作、药物过量病例、严重过敏反应、中风症状以及各种各样的疾病。你无法预知每个班次会发生什么，这本身就让人感到压力山大。交接会议结束后，戈德斯坦博士开始查房。所以我要去看的这位病人有多种医疗问题，包括器官移植。我随行前往，但为了尊重病人的隐私，我没有进入任何检查室。
I saw that she looked like she was in significant discomfort. Dr. Goldstein says this is a complicated case, and the person will probably be admitted to the hospital for a few days. Dr. Corey Goldstein moves to the next patient, and the next and the next. Over the course of an eight-hour shift, he rarely quits moving or takes breaks, considering the fast pace, the high volume of patients, the constant noise and beeping, and the often high-stakes decision-making, this is a stressful job. To understand how people work in such tense environments, I talked to psychologist Dennis Stolley.
我看到她看起来非常不舒服。戈尔斯坦医生说这是一个复杂的病例，病人可能需要住院几天。科里·戈尔斯坦医生走向下一个病人，接着是一个又一个。在八小时的值班过程中，他几乎没有停歇，也不休息。考虑到快节奏、大量的患者、不断的噪音和蜂鸣声，以及往往高风险的决策，这是一份压力很大的工作。为了了解人们如何在如此紧张的环境中工作，我采访了心理学家丹尼斯·斯托利。
He's the head of applied psychology at the American Psychological Association. Much of his research is focused on the workplace, human performance, and leadership. Dennis Stolley says every job involves some amount of stress, and that's not necessarily a bad thing. That stress in the right dose is part of what helps us get out of bed in the morning because we're concerned about the consequences of not getting those things done. And so generally speaking, stress is not a bad thing. It's just part of life. It only becomes a bad thing when it starts to become unmanaged.
他是美国心理学会应用心理学负责人。他的许多研究都集中在职场、人类绩效和领导力上。丹尼斯·斯托利表示，每项工作都伴随着一定程度的压力，这不一定是件坏事。适度的压力是我们早晨起床的动力之一，因为我们担心未能完成这些事情的后果。因此，总的来说，压力并不是坏事。它只是生活的一部分。只有当压力开始不受控制时，它才会变成坏事。
Well, the number of patients in the emergency department stresses me out, and I have to imagine it's overwhelming for the staff at times too. But when I asked Dr. Corey Goldstein about it, he was matter of fact. Yeah, we are taking care of a lot of people simultaneously, but, you know, when you do anything a lot, you get used to it, right? Yeah. Psychologist Dennis Stolley of the American Psychological Association says high-functional teams in stressful work environments like this typically have good communication and strong
嗯，急诊室里病人的数量让我感到压力山大，我想这对医护人员来说有时也一定是难以承受的。但当我向科里·戈尔斯坦医生询问此事时，他却表现得很平静。是的，我们同时在照顾很多人，但是，你知道的，当你经常做某事时，你就习惯了，对吧？是的。美国心理学会的心理学家丹尼斯·斯托利表示，像这样压力重重的职场环境中的高效团队，通常具备良好的沟通能力和强大的
psychological safety. Here's what he means by that. People feel safe to speak up and ask questions, to admit mistakes, without a fear that they're going to be punished or embarrassed for doing so. And it's that kind of communication that can really be effective and let people work together in a productive kind of way, it can become very unproductive if people feel a fear of speaking up. I definitely saw moments when the emergency department staff seemed to have strong psychological safety. Like when a resident named Tim was briefing Dr. Corey Goldstein about a case. You put a dime room? I did.
心理安全感。这就是他所指的意思。人们感到可以畅所欲言、提出问题、承认错误，而不必担心因此受到惩罚或尴尬。正是这种沟通才能真正发挥作用，让人们以富有成效的方式合作；而如果人们害怕直言不讳，合作就会变得非常低效。我确实看到过急诊室员工似乎拥有强烈心理安全感的时刻。就像一个名叫蒂姆的住院医师向科里·戈尔斯坦医生汇报病例时那样。你放了一个双人间？是的。
Now tell you why. Okay. He's coming here with Disney has to camera while arrest today. He described as Disney is more like a situation with lightheadedness. Everyone on the emergency department team seems sharp. Roles were well defined, and Dr. Corey Goldstein was calmly in charge. I asked psychologist Dennis Stolle how much strong leadership factors into workplace stress levels. For a highly skilled more junior worker, a critical resource to have is a highly skilled leader.
现在告诉你原因。好的。他来这里是因为今天有心搏骤停。他将其描述为头晕目眩的情况。急诊科团队中的每个人看起来都很敏锐。角色定义明确，科里·戈尔斯坦医生沉着地掌控着全局。我问心理学家丹尼斯·斯托利，强大的领导力对职场压力水平有多大影响。对于一个技能高超但资历较浅的员工来说，拥有的关键资源是一个技能高超的领导者。
And that reduces your stress level tremendously because you know. you've got that person there who you can count on. Now, vice versa, for the leader to know that they have highly skilled workers who are going to feel free to speak up when they have something to say and know what they're doing, dramatically lowers the stress level for the leader. It's obvious to me. Dr. Corey Goldstein is good at his emergency medicine job and likes it. But even if a person loves what they do and works on a strong team, stress is strong. still stress. Psychologist Dennis Stolley says ongoing occupational stress can obviously burn some people out. It is a situation where stress is unmanaged to the point that a person begins to
这会极大地降低你的压力水平，因为你知道你身边有那个你可以依靠的人。反过来，对于领导者来说，知道他们拥有技能高超的员工，并且在有话要说时敢于直言不讳、知道自己在做什么，会极大地降低领导者的压力水平。对我来说显而易见的是，科里·戈尔斯坦医生擅长他的急诊医学工作并且热爱它。但即使一个人热爱自己的工作并身处一个强大的团队中，压力依然是压力。心理学家丹尼斯·斯托利表示，持续的职业压力显然会让一些人筋疲力尽。这种情况下的压力不受控制，以至于一个人开始
experience emotional exhaustion and beginning to feel ineffective. Oftentimes it may be there's so much work coming at me that nothing I can do will ever allow me to catch up. Stolley says unmanaged workplace burnout can have serious consequences for a person. Chronic stress can lead to clinical depression and anxiety. He says a protective tool for mental health is something called psychological capital. That's different from psychological safety mentioned earlier. Stolli says it's basically values a person can lean on during tough times. Psychological capital includes the elements of having,
体验到情绪上的精疲力竭，并开始感到无能为力。通常情况可能是，有太多工作涌向我，以至于我无论做什么都无法赶上。斯托利表示，失控的职场职业倦怠会给一个人带来严重的后果。慢性压力会导致临床抑郁症和焦虑症。他说，保护心理健康的一个工具有个专门的名词叫心理资本。这与前面提到的心理安全感不同。斯托利表示，这基本上是人们在困难时期可以倚靠的价值观。心理资本包括拥有……等要素
having hope and a sense of personal efficacy and resilience and optimism. One of the things that can actually make an individual begin to develop more psychological capital is by being around team members who already have a lot of psychological capital. It's almost contagious in that sense. So even if workers in high-stress jobs have all the protective factors we've heard about, psychological capital, being on a skilled team with strong leadership, and having a healthy amount of psychological safety, is it really good for a person to work in this kind of high-pressure job day after day? The American Psychological Association says employers can do all kinds of
拥有希望、自我效能感、韧性以及乐观精神。实际上，能让个人开始发展更多心理资本的方法之一，就是身边有那些已经拥有丰富心理资本的团队成员。从这个意义上说，它几乎是会传染的。因此，即使从事高压工作的员工具备了我们所听到的所有保护性因素，如心理资本、拥有强大领导力的熟练团队，以及健康的心理安全感，日复一日地从事这种高压工作对一个人来说真的好吗？美国心理学会表示，雇主可以采取各种
fundamental things to prevent workplace burnout, like make sure workers have realistic workloads and regular check-ins with their managers. Psychologist Dennis Stolley says one of the best things workplaces can offer their employees is vacation time. The research is clear. Time away from work is essential, but it has to be a real break. It's not the vacation where you take your laptop and work from the beach. That's not a vacation. It's actually taking time away from work. I followed up on this with Dr. Corey Goldstein at Rush University Medical Center in Chicago. He says he takes vacation time and has no problem disconnecting from the emergency department when he's out. He says working in emergency medicine gives him a certain perspective on stress in general. A challenging shift can
预防职场倦怠的基本措施，比如确保员工有现实的工作量，并与管理者进行定期沟通。心理学家丹尼斯·斯托利表示，职场能为员工提供的最好事情之一就是假期。研究很明确。远离工作的时间至关重要，但那必须是真正的休息。那不是那种带着笔记本电脑在海滩上工作的假期。那不是度假。那实际上是抽出时间远离工作。我在芝加哥拉什大学医学中心就此采访了科里·戈尔斯坦医生。他说他会休假，而且在离开急诊室时能毫无困难地与工作断开连接。他说，从事急诊医学工作让他对一般压力有了一种特殊的看法。充满挑战的值班可以
make the rest of his day feel pretty manageable. For a call to mind, I'm Jessica Barri in Chicago. You're listening to The Strain of Stress. special report from call to mind. I'm Angela Davis. As we just heard, taking time off from work is a great way to manage stress and prevent job burnout. But it's just not possible for everyone to take a vacation. And some of the factors that stress us are things we can't take a break from. The research is clear. Stress is something that needs to be managed and our mental health depends on it. Dr. Alyssa Epple, who we heard from a bit ago, wrote a book called The Stress Prescription. She shares science-back tips that everyone can do to reduce stress in just minutes.
让他的其余时间感觉相当容易掌控。我是芝加哥的杰西卡·巴里，为您现场报道。您收听的是《压力的张力》。来自 Call to Mind 的特别报道。我是安吉拉·戴维斯。正如我们刚才所听到的，休假是管理压力和预防职业倦怠的好方法。但并不是每个人都能去度假。而且，给我们带来压力的某些因素是我们无法暂停的。研究很明确。压力是需要被管理的东西，我们的心理健康依赖于此。不久前我们采访过的爱丽丝·埃普尔医生写了一本名为《压力处方》的书。她分享了科学支持的小建议，任何人都能在短短几分钟内用来减轻压力。
She suggests doing mindful check-ins, slowing down, breathing, and focusing on where you feel the stress in your body. Dr. Eppel also says nature is a powerful tool we just don't use enough. being outside to breathe fresh air and take in natural sounds and sights can turn down our stressful thoughts and make room to relax. Plus, nature is free, no prescription needed. When I spoke with Dr. Eppel, we also discuss how to handle all the uncertainty of stress. I think a lot of what is stressing many people out right now is this feeling of there's so much I can't control. I couldn't agree with you more. So if you think about what is bothering you most right now, it's very likely a situation where you don't have much control.
她建议进行正念打卡、放慢脚步、呼吸，并专注于你身体哪个部位感受到了压力。埃普尔医生还表示，大自然是一个强大的工具，而我们却没有充分利用它。身处户外呼吸新鲜空气、聆听大自然的声音和欣赏景色，可以平息我们紧张的思绪，腾出空间来放松。另外，大自然是免费的，不需要处方。当我与埃普尔医生交谈时，我们还讨论了如何应对压力的种种不确定性。我认为现在给许多人带来压力的很大一部分原因，是这种“有太多事情我无法控制”的感觉。我不能更同意你的看法了。因此，如果你想想目前最困扰你的是什么，那很可能是一个你无法掌控太多的情况。
And yet, our mind so easily creates a big stress response around that, even though we can't resolve the situation. Once we recognize what we can and can't control, we can actually what I call drop the rope. I suggest starting with thinking about one of the situations that you are carrying around, that creates, a lot of stress in your life and asking yourself, how much of this situation do I control? In many cases, there's very little. And so in this moment, allowing ourselves to realize that we cannot solve it, that our mind may be problem solving, may be worrying, but that the most healthy thing we can do right now is to allow ourselves to put that down for now. Those repeated experiences of letting go is one of our most important survival skills.
然而，我们的心灵却极其容易围绕这一点产生巨大的压力反应，尽管我们无法解决这种情况。一旦我们认识到什么是我们能控制的，什么是我们不能控制的，我们就可以实际采取我称之为“放下绳子”的做法。我建议从思考你所承载的一种情境开始，这种情境在你的生活中造成了很大的压力，并问问你自己：“这种情况有多少是我能控制的？”在许多情况下，微乎其微。因此，在此刻，我们要允许自己认识到我们无法解决它，我们的心灵可能在试图解决问题、可能在担忧，但我们此刻能做的最健康的事情，就是允许自己暂时放下它。这种反复放手的经历是我们最重要的生存技能之一。
Just thinking about that makes me feel lighter. Yes, and we might not even be aware that we're carrying them. So I like to picture us trying to pull on a boulder that can't move. And if we can then just say to ourselves, drop the rope and let yourself feel relief from all of that strain, that can be very powerful. I say to myself, drop the rope several times a day. That was psychologist, Alyssa Epple, from the University of California, San Francisco,
光是想想这一点就让我觉得轻松多了。是的，我们甚至可能都没有意识到自己一直背负着它们。所以我喜欢把我们想象成试图去拉一块无法移动的巨石。如果我们随后能对自己说：“放下绳子”，并让自己感受到压力释放带来的宽慰，那将会非常强大。我每天对自已说好几次“放下绳子”。以上是来自加利福尼亚大学旧金山分校的心理学家爱丽丝·埃普尔，
and author of the book The Stress Prescription. I have to admit these interviews and reports about stress have hit home from me in August of 2025. A phone call from a nurse revealed I had breast cancer. My first response was, I don't have time for this. I am already stressed. I work full-time as a journalist,
她也是《压力处方》一书的作者。我必须承认，这些关于压力的采访和报道深深触动了我。在2025年8月，一通来自护士的电话显示我患上了乳腺癌。我的第一反应是：“我可没时间得这个。我压力已经够大了。我是一名全职记者，
and much of the news is about division, uncertainty and violence. I'm a wife and the mother of two young adults who are navigating new jobs in cities far away from home. I have high blood pressure. And now I have to handle a cancer diagnosis? Well, I learned I can handle it as long as I ask for help and use some of my coping skills. Here's what works for me. Music. I listen to music a lot. For me, it's heal. I put together a recovery playlist when I was on leave of absence from work. Here's one of the songs I've been listening to repeatedly. It's called Handle That, and it's a collaboration by Artone, Simo, and FCA Jazz. Movement also helps me manage chronic stress. It does wonders. Going to the gym, to walk on the elliptical machine or treadmill, then sitting in the steam sauna.
许多新闻都关乎分裂、不确定性和暴力。我是一位妻子，也是两个年轻成年人的母亲，他们正在远离家乡的城市里摸索着开展新工作。我患有高血压。而现在我还要应对癌症诊断？好吧，我了解到只要我寻求帮助并运用一些应对技巧，我就能应付它。以下对我有效的方法是：音乐。我经常听音乐。对我来说，音乐是治愈的。在我请病假期间，我制作了一个康复播放列表。这是我一直在反复听的一首歌。它叫《Handle That》，是由 Artone、Simo 和 FCA Jazz 合作的作品。运动也能帮我控制慢性压力。它有奇效。去健身房在椭圆机或跑步机上走走，然后坐在蒸汽桑拿房里。
It boosts my energy level and relaxes my mind. mind. Getting outdoors and taking in some fresh air has been powerful as well. I also meet with a therapist every two weeks to talk about my worries and how setting boundaries can help me have more joy. I am now cancer-free, but I still deal with stress. The difference now is that I have a much better idea of how to drop the rope. You've been listening to The Strain of Stress, a special report. A special from Call to Mind, American Public Media's initiative to foster new conversations about mental health. This program was produced and written by our senior producer, Jessica Barre, and edited by Stephen Smith. Our technical director is Alex Simpson, and Hans Buto scored the show. I'm Angela Davis. It's been a
它提升了我的精力水平，放松了我的大脑。走到户外呼吸新鲜空气同样非常有效。我还每两周与治疗师见面一次，谈论我的担忧以及设定界限如何能帮我获得更多快乐。我现在已经癌症康复了，但我依然要应对压力。现在的不同之处在于，我对于如何放下绳子有了更好的概念。您收听的是特别报道《压力的张力》。来自 Call to Mind 的特别报道，这是美国公共传媒旨在促进关于心理健康新对话的倡议。这个节目由我们的资深制作人杰西卡·巴里制作和撰写，史蒂芬·史密斯剪辑。我们的技术总监是亚历克斯·辛普森，汉斯·布托为本节目配乐。我是安吉拉·戴维斯。非常
pleasure to be your host. To find all our past programs, visit our website at call to mind now.org. Thank you for listening to The Strain of Stress. A special report by Call to Mind. This is APM, American Public Media. If you liked this podcast, make sure to follow and subscribe to Call to Mind in your favorite podcast app and leave us a review. Thanks for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
荣幸能担任您的主持人。要查找我们所有的往期节目，请访问我们的网站 call to mind now.org。感谢您收听《压力的张力》。来自 Call to Mind 的特别报道。这是 APM，美国公共传媒。如果您喜欢这个播客，请务必在您喜爱的播客应用中关注并订阅 Call to Mind，并给我们留下一条评论。感谢收听。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。